i remembered brazilian football after one
time on the grid leonel fernández
[Music]
venezuela cuba and its president
aelson has january brazil the average at
nenê online i love you baby and one life
to help january 1st she only has two
cameras from  ufam chrome
[Music]
if I go I'll be here in the municipality
soon the local newspaper nation mentioning
its buggy serves six in play off shore
the next economic bulletin from far the
feet where it promotes between wen
portland franchise in the area of 60 thousand euros los
Cabos Mexico Your
Excellency Mr Dollar Both the
President of the United States of America
in My Ministers Members
of the Delegations of the States of Brazil
Ladies and Gentlemen and
the Press Professionals or Raspberry Ladies and
Gentlemen Readers Advance Mineiro
Professor Usa Thank you very much
the event brings in your warm
hospitality ih  the organ is an honor to
be waston they renan
my first bilateral visit since the
elected president of brazil I
take advantage of the option  opportunity to invite you
to present but it will be in vain and they have
received this Brazilian award you understand
and a lot in common
I have always been a great admirer
results unite myers and this admiration
increased with the arrival of your
excellency president cristina
this meeting of ours resumes humanism with
partnership management
at the same time the average in brazil in which
the united states issued today in addition
we are going to issues that have been on the agenda
for decades and we open new fronts of
cooperation
this is the time of all vast expanse that
exists in
brazil brazil and  the united states can see the
final
today brazil has a president is
not this one is not anti-american brazil
dance of an unprecedented case is the last
decades he the reforms we are
undertaking are transforming brazil
is an even more attractive partner
we firmly follow the mutiny of  home and
that dealing with public accounts
will transform the business environment.
I sew American and main
income  so from brasil signed the cd and their
reports understood as a
very clean gesture of recognition to mark even
more and had a union of forces tend
to include in their body and several
close doors both countries can continue
to be protagonists
I think our relations  and man ray
that is why we have activated the voter on the 11th of
june
Brazil and the united states we have also
with priority launch of the
energy forum is not to do it in oil they tried and
others fone lot and net as the signal and
let the government
so the government  Brazilian granted
visa exemption for
American citizens or to stimulate a
champagne tourism and business in
the letter aspect the decoupling
we signed the agreement where I was on the go and
technology I always wanted that I would give myself
the luxury of launching alcantara to
any action  The military has also
expanded in the search for partnership or in
defense systems, if
science, technology and innovation activities only receive
those who can occupy  r this growing meeting
if our relationship and condemn christ
hence our proposal is strong and innovation to the
whole brazil and united states if it is in the
fight against terrorism this is the
first result is a matter of
urgency our peoples - we decided to
strengthen
it  is a witch of common interest they
nuts or win between the
venezuelan dictatorial regime and holds a debate
in an international coalition
readily known as the forum of são
paulo and they are for that reason he himself
conquering the power neither of
latin america or through inclusive democratic way
not  this project is from brazil instructed
the anthem iron and saying that brazil
has evolved and the exit is also normal in
guaranteeing freedoms arrival
respect for the traditional family because it has a
show of moura always gave our servant in
hawaii taking into account the hydrology of gender
each politically correct gentle  and i
thought he was still waiting that in
franca de xira josé ronald ramon in
israel and japan in brazil is his way
to manage transmitted
in the following sentence leave your authorship
more off in the stock market and must say that
the government can do without the attack I
don't want to find you in the euro zone the
united states changed and Domingos refers
in Brazil also started to change in 2009
pregnant women  we stay together for the good of
our peoples between wanting to leave we will have
merica great niche that brazil is 80
years old and i am also not once again
brazil expresses my segment incidentally that the
treasury and between the two largest
democracies not died only
brazil won  god bless my
thanks sir president who has the
average willian has been giving the voter feel one
day the candidate josé lopes the best
the dollar was in crisis i
didn't leave don't leave any n 001 the
final phase
there the dollar and the fpso osx-  1 go there is very
easy at the mall is to discuss how a
great look my family and cleidson there
in 'extra' people who look at my were i
feel at home both in boa vista capital
of roraima bo  the capital view of roraima
outside if it wanted it could broadcast it
will still rain in this beautiful museum exhibits
pieces the state sefaz but it's easy to say
that i am that's what she wants a
much calmer check although i
understand the evolution that was the action
irã in  may be landing
eurozone countries eagerness for champion was at the
house at the time explained there i only spoke to
michael before equipment lacquer a
terrible thing that was
caixin santana says el woods with baby to put
a little e-mail always in this matter that
judges  there is the wall of at
this province the whole neighborhood alto
good afternoon president simone iglesias da
firefighter i liked it simone grows the
chance of the north they made the
average installment reached tonight percent of the
issues contraf is full of the
peter river in the long the kick already thinking
positively in the middle and peel and
saw will not be able to become a great
delegation of God wills and make it not
remembered the history of everything that is
foreseen yet the des  spend the water
bionorte unfortunately for
natural sources using the mother in the pb plant is
rightly with the rope in day and night in
notes passages wage this battle
with life in the lane on your side the ghost the
lapt the lord of april danny granger and
her  and cora arrives the chance was from
flamengo
they don't think higuaín in the face that today to
postpone in places of the night and during
today yesterday I create
the guarantee the field there is good it was hit
by a spring
so bayern since facebook  and google
adwords
forgets the minister defends the church has
to make an effort at the end of the year and now it
would be that try to take care of your
forces the show a lot around the country after
the legislature and in the internal a17 is the case
of the military a person very much in my mother
in the past the dae like what was done
with me in brazil the team
starts operating flights lam heong iok it hurts a little but
they don't know who i am i am not a
technician yet in brazil being eight
samples and urinated on television in another
context and  wi  llem buiter five more
antony and mônica gomes asked for union and
death
lisbon was the estadão
mr brazil sold that day and then the
former ruler way of putting
brazil 101 where either this business has seen
these behind wish but there is a bottle
of  champagne profile is full of blood
billions minor of the president
the ubs has a way to describe wishing in which
until now president his president the
scenario is the united states expect the
decrease of china's influence in
brazil
yesterday minister rossi said he wants to
discover our lady
paulo  10 which is an easy opponent but it
was on the street arbat standard a cacex where the
team nor who the violent deaths
pranksters passes bonfim the long account of
fahel and class to do that also
twinned in homs i'm going well speak still
know is that awaits him  now by kites the
same type of apple product arrives it
has been kept beautiful techweb that
matt jones won oxxo czeca